-[music fades]
-[Laura] What are you doing here?
What does it look like I'm doing? [scoffs]
[sighs] I'm winning.
Massimo made a huge mistake
by underestimating the anger
of the abandoned woman.
[laughing]
[suspenseful music continues playing]
What are you doing here?
You were supposed to wait in Sicily
until the negotiations were over.
You know them?
Honey, we were the ones
who pushed you into his arms.
[Adriano breathing shakily]
[in Italian] Did you really think
you could just say the word
and I'd disappear from your life?
That I would've lived
off your handouts in exile?
No, Massimo. No.
[breathing shakily]
You finally showed your weakness.
Question is,
do you really think this little whore's
worth the whole empire our father created?
[clicks tongue wildly, snorts]
Though I have to say,
she's not bad. [kisses]
[kisses]
[kisses, sucks teeth]
[in English] Sometimes I wonder
if your child
would've looked more like you…
[smacks lips] …or like her.
-♪ I tried to forget your name… ♪
-Huh?
It's a pity.
It's a pity that we will never know.
Because of the accident.
♪ To myself ♪
-♪ Are we damned? ♪
-[sounds echoing]
[shot echoes]
♪ We almost lost this game… ♪
♪ This is the end ♪
[music swells]
[shot echoes]
[music fades]
["Another Day" playing]
♪ There was a time when I felt inside ♪
♪ Love and hate, but you were mine ♪
♪ You were the only reason to make ♪
♪ My eyes smile over and over again ♪
♪ And I just feel this fear ♪
♪ Is eating me inside now ♪
♪ If you believed in my eyes ♪
♪ We would've had another day ♪
♪ And you just see me inside ♪
♪ I swear we would have another day ♪
♪ Another day ♪